[Music]
floating markets have been at the center
of communities in thailand for hundreds
of years
they were originally built along canals
and rivers at a time when water
transport played an important role in
daily life
one of the most popular in thailand is
the ampawa floating market 45 miles from
bangkok
it stretches 30 miles along a canal on
the maeklong river
and today hundreds of vendors use the
empower floating market to sell and cook
a wide variety of delicious thai dishes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
okay just watch
three
two
one
this is thailand's mekong market
about an hour south of bangkok
every day beginning at 6 20 in the
morning a train runs through makelong
railway market one of the largest
produce and seafood markets in thailand
through the stalls selling fruit ice
cream
fish
through everything and if you're
wondering which came first the market of
the train
the answer is the market
[Music]
the makelong railway built a commuter
train to bangkok back in 1905.
the track they laid ran right through
the middle of this market which had been
around for decades
rather than moving the vendors stayed
put adjusting their business to the
train times
eight times a day
seven days a week
this system has been perfected over the
years with produce just inches from the
trains wheels tourists and vendors wait
as the train passes through
then everything goes back to normal
or at least as normal as an active train
line market can be
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
again
[Music]
i'm sophie martner hungarian food writer
and author of 11 cookbooks this is the
central market hall the largest oldest
and most beautiful indoor market of
budapest
come and see some of the vendors
[Music]
on board
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you will find here everything different
varieties of peppers tomatoes fermented
cucumbers and everything as needed for
hungarian cooking which is so much more
than just blush
[Music]
colombia land of flavor and color but
few know about the incredibly rich and
unusual fruits this country has to offer
thanks to its biodiversity the land
produces delicacies
like the prehistoric looking guanabana
and the mysterious magostinos
and that brings us here
this is not your typical grocery store
produce section
this is palo kemal
[Music]
welcome to bogata's quintessential
market
this is the place to find the most
mysterious looking strange-flavored
fruits across the palace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is a special place bursting with color
and flavor offering the world an
irreplaceable array of nectrous gifts
of course as long as they are in season
you